STEPHANIE WONG: Get ready,
because Google Cloud Next
starts today on a
virtual screen near you.
Yes, that means you can
keep your sweats on.
And we're going to start each
morning with a live broadcast
and keynote.
There will be two channels to
join that play simultaneously,
so feel free to
switch between them.
It's up to you to explore our
live interactive expert Q&As,
breakout sessions, and demos.
Check out our expert
playlists, including mine,
or make your own
at g.co/cloud/next.
As for day one, check
out the opening keynote.
Our CEO, Thomas
Kurian, will talk
about how our products
have helped customers
adapt to complexities
and challenges
and lead to opportunities.
I can't reveal
too much just yet,
but expect to hear about
our biggest launches,
captivating customer stories,
and TK's view on Google Cloud's
feature.
Keep an eye out for some
exciting cameos, as well.
Then join me in my
keynote, "Data Cloud,
Simply transform with a
universal data platform."
VP of databases and
analytics joins me
as we introduce the future
of data, analytics, and AI
at Google Cloud.
We'll highlight our latest
technology for products,
including BigQuery, Spanner,
Looker, and Vertex AI.
And don't miss it, because
there will be a live demo.
Check out the live Q&A
afterwards to interact with us.
Then we'll move into
our Workspace spotlight,
"How it's done with Google
Workspace," where they'll
announce launches that are
helping customers transform
collaboration and support
genuine human connection
in a hybrid world.
And, yes, there will
be a live demo and Q&A.
And the day will wrap up with a
spotlight session on diversity,
equity, and inclusion
to help you build
a safe, inclusive, and
diverse workforce that
thrives and innovates.
Check out channel 2 for
partner-customer innovation
and DEI spotlights, featuring
our partners like Atos,
Accenture, and Deloitte.
I do want to also remind
you that we have a bunch
of interactive events, like Q&As
and learning pathways for cloud
infrastructure, AI, or security.
And if you're like, hey,
skip all the talking.
I just want to see some
live demo action, then
filter in the right
filter bar in the catalog
and you'll find the
sessions with live demos.
Then add them to your
own custom playlist.
OK, so get ready for day
one and connect on social
by hashtagging
#GoogleCloudNext, and reach out
to me @stephr_wong.